[Music]
and truth hurts news submitted by secret
cabinet
liz' wants a judge to decide that she
didn't plagiarize her major breakout hit
truth hurts there she's gay who Liz oh
oh so this is Liz oh she's rising it
yeah she's being accused but by these
two men for plagiarizing her very
popular hit truth hurts and so they are
claiming that although they did they did
it demo but the lyrics sound like it's
written by her like I took a DNA test
and oh that's actually the exact lyric
that were focusing on so she's a hundred
percent a [__] yeah that part so here's
the story I'm like two guys wrote that
these two songwriters named Justin and
Jeremiah Jeremiah they came forward to
publicly claimed that that Psalm borrows
parts of the melody from this demo that
they recorded with Liz Oh back in April
2017 called healthy and they said quote
we've tried to sort this out quietly for
the last two years only asking for five
percent each but we're shut down every
time so what they ended up doing is they
came out with this clip of the
comparison and I will show it to you
[Applause]
hold on why wouldn't she [__] cover
our bases hold on
might be the record label oh I'm trying
to prejudge everything well we just lost
graduation is a part of JK news we got
it how am I gonna dig holes for myself
if you're trying to stop me from doing
it yeah my show about you and I want you
guys to not dig holes that song healthy
which was back in 2017 so Liz Oh came
out saying this it sounds totally
different to me oh my god like [__]
what's-his-name vanilla ice with Queen
oh yeah she posted hey y'all as I've
shared before in 2017 while working on a
demo I saw a meme that resonated with me
a meme that made me feel like 100
percent bad [__] I sang that line in
the demo and I later used the line in
truth hurts the men who now claim a
piece of truth hurts did not help did
not help me write any part of that song
they had nothing to do with the line or
how I chose to sing it there was no one
in the room when I wrote truth hurts
except me Ricky Reid and my tears that
song is my life and it's words are my
truth I later learned that a tweet
inspired the meme the creator of the
tweet is the person I am sharing my
success with not these men period thank
you to everyone who has supported me and
my song xoxo so this is the tweet that
she was talking about so this other
songwriter called Nina lioness she
tweeted this out in February of 2017 I
did a DNA test and found out her new
present that [__] soul is Oh sing that
she saw she came across a meme that used
this tweet so she never knew that
she had never seen that tweet which she
points out in this other tweet she says
truth hurts was written in June FYI
someone made a meme on IG that said I
wanted to present that [__] and we were
inspired I gave that meme credit when I
talked about making the song I've never
seen your viral tweet but I'm glad it
exists so now the bottom line is she has
agreed to give credit to this whole
writer for that lyric and that's that
tweet was a song was a songwriter that
just wrote that yeah tweet she tweeted
that out someone took that made into a
meme lisslow came across it you saw the
means it got inspired put that lyric
into her song she never credited it or
she did mention it like oh I got that
from a meme but she never gave her soul
the original thing that she decided to
use that meme on was the song with the
two guys so now the guys are going back
and saying we wrote that that was out
exactly and now the guys are trying to
come in and say hey wars are 10% the
guys say they wrote it or they're saying
that they did the melody no well both
both things cuz they load up [__] house
I'm just saying the melody was the same
yeah but she's saying that she she did
that melody on her own when she recorded
that demo with them that's what she's
claiming like the way she said it
yeah like the same way that she said it
in truth her exactly like that part
she's responsible for so she claimed
mm-hmm interesting I'm not a lawyer so I
know nothing here but you sounded really
stretch things well thank you very much
it just kind of sucks that now that
she's big and like famous that there's
people are trying to come after that was
my queen is that part of it though it is
yeah that's what's sad about it standard
so Liz's attorney said in a statement
today we filed a lawsuit on Liz's behalf
to establish in a court of law that the
rise ins which are the songwriters are
not writers of truth hurts and have no
right to profit from the song success
the raisin did not collaborate with Liz
Oh or anyone else to create the song and
they did not help write any of the
material that they now seek to profit
from which is why they expressly
renounced and
claim to the work and writing months ago
and lawsuit makes abundantly clear wow
that's some shady [__] is they're trying
to they're trying to do some dirt yeah
I'd like so afterwards they're trying to
get the public against them because it
illegally [__] but they're trying to
publicly yeah isn't that amazing
Kathy can't she sue back if it if they
could prove that it hurt her business Oh
true if that could be well it's like
those [__] that went after Michael
because they couldn't get money from his
estate you had those [__] who got
diddled by Michael going after Michael
[Music]
no that's true he just sucked a dick
yeah that's good talk about this what's
uh what's your opinion on though though
so I think that Michael probably watched
children spread their ass shoes for him
I think that that's pretty likely do you
really think that didn't happen
how about this let's just ask this do
you really think that Michael Jackson
never laid in a bed with a kid and said
I want to marry you sounds like
something he would say I'm not taking
them I don't think he would mean it
romantically or sexually this Polly
playing house yeah come on
and he's that mom he's a grown [__]
man dude so you don't think it happened
you don't think that's about me no no
this is this is the [__] of like
perception yeah Michael Jackson was a
grown man physiologically a grown yeah
yeah all this [__] like he had a minor
child he should be allowed to sleep a
little boy don't you know it's the
stupidest [__] I've ever heard logically
in my life why won't even though you got
you felt for the mean dude Michael
Jackson has the mind of a child because
Joe Jackson abused him when he was a kid
so therefore he tries to stay a child
but they call this heated children and
it's totally fine let that's this Peter
I wish I what's your position on this
now I'm curious I you know this one's a
tough one because Michael Jackson makes
some of the best music Pro so the
question is like him I think he did it
like honestly just because it just it
just [__] matches who like it's just
obviously wait you divide the martyr's
kids
now that's a [__] kid but I think some
of the stuff that he's being accused for
like it's it's watching kids have spread
their ass
inconsistencies in their stories yeah
there were kids I just think like aggro
they were teen and you know with kids
like there's something going on like a
grown man that prefers it doesn't matter
what excuses but a grown man that
prefers to be around kids all the time
it's just there's something
psychologically wrong wrong cuz he was
never he never had a childhood I mean
that's the other the [__] because
we're untrained psychologists right what
do you say about the the guys that
actually study molesting and pedophiles
and they all came together to do a study
on Michael Jackson to see if he fit the
profile based off his lifestyle based
off of the FBI raids all the evidence
that they found and then they all
concluded that all included there's a
very very extremely low chance of him
actually being a pedophile exhibit he
doesn't exhibit those behaviors every
night want me to ruin your want me to
ruin your dreams so I know someone
really close to me that works for
Children Services that was like oh yeah
we've had a couple of his kids like the
files here and that stuff is true
Michael Jackson look let me go back to
where yours is how come they didn't come
out and [__] threaten them new Mark
Geragos came out on [__] TV and he's
like you want to come out for Michael
will [__] end you well here's the
thing though typically a pedophile
Melissa mouth monster will have a
roughly around 100 to 200 victims right
so with that volume right why is it that
it's only three with high
inconsistencies because I mean think
about mark 3 is and it's Michael Jackson
you know no but that's the thing is why
didn't people come out they did in the
90s and they got four no they did it who
else came out besides I talking him up
and the 90s and then there was there was
another group in 2012 it's the same
group though no it's not the 2012 was a
different group of kids and then the and
then the the kids for the 90s were asked
to defend Michael no that's one kid in
in in the in 2000 no mo two of them two
of them from the from the 90s case were
asked to defend Michael oh the one that
made the documentary
you can't go back to her you're saying
no because you're saying that it's like
all these psychologists like studying
him right but the thing is like she
wouldn't be a normal pedophile you can't
put him in the same campus but what is a
normal pedophile don't whatever you
don't study pedophiles you wouldn't know
what a normal own a pedophile I'm just
saying like you can't compare him like
it like you just can't compare it's like
it's like perfect you can't compare Mike
would you tell guys that study
pedophiles and understand the psychology
behind pedophiles that their evidence is
irrelevant start and they don't
understand what it's like to be that
famous or they understand peddle you
know if you're I don't even know if
you're setting that correctly either I
don't know if it's like guess what all
psychologists got together say Michael
Jackson's chill I don't know if it's
that open oh but it's a study group that
emphasizes pedophilia well that new
evidence Gio never brought up but the
source is also questionable in my
opinion the source is questionable yeah
that's what they would do Michael
Jackson's made came out and said yo I
saw him naked with kids oh and then what
discredit her by saying oh she had a
drug charge because it was proven that
she was paid and then that was thrown
out of court that's why they buy what
she was paid by a group a record company
that wanted to take over the lights in
the ricin sink licensing [__] yeah
and they prove that so that was that's
why they threw out her case so because
they they they all the people that came
out the witnesses now his name is
tarnished right but the thing is people
going on here say and and the none of
these things flied in court I've never
found kiddie porn at his house no never
ever
but then they ever sleep in beds with
kids with his own family yes but with
zero kiddie porn know with with that's
crazy though no he's a minute to sleep
in with other kids others yeah a lot I
don't know about that well he has fluffy
beds
we're talking about even McCullough he
was like yeah I slept through the same
bed with what they never had sex right
but I'm just saying he would grow on his
[__] the kids so he didn't he would
target the right kid but you know what
we're trying to groom them to subscribe
so if you like this video
[Music]